people love superheroes. They swoop out of the sky and save the day people love that
cozy feeling that superheroes give them
well well well you
It's not what it looks like I thought we had
an understanding and when you're trying
welcome back everyone is Charlie Amazon just finished shooting the boys season 2
they dropped a new teaser they let
us know what the release dates going to
be there's a bunch of new characters
that they're introducing so we'll break
it all down I'll be doing videos for the
boys season two all year long so be sure
to subscribe if you're brand new to the
channel they'll be dropping more stuff
later this year and early next year too
the new teaser for season 2 just
highlights butchers voiceover hyping up
the idea that everyone loves superheroes
but because they're focusing on the
footage of homeland or Sun it's much
more insidious the idea that this little
kid probably has no idea who his
father's been his whole life it has
wanted to know where do I come from
why do I have these weird powers so
he'll eat up anything that homeland er
tells him which is really dangerous
because not only is he this powerful
little superhero kid in homeland er
probably has no idea how to be a good
father might wind up corrupting him it
might wind up turning into something
even worse than homeland er like there's
this whole idea that they try to present
him is the worst person on the show
maybe not necessarily a villain but the
closest thing to it but there are other
characters that are actually a little
bit worse storm front is a good example
of that I've already done a storm front
video so I will link it at the end of
this and as they said during that scene
his mother butcher's wife never told him
that homeland er was his father so that
makes it even more likely that he'll eat
up anything that homeland er says then
as you get more of that voiceover you're
reminded about Hughie's arc during
season 1 and how his eyes were slowly
being open to butchers truth about
superheroes that they're just as bad and
terrible as anyone else most of them are
even very good at being a superhero in
the only reason why everyone believes in
them so much believe this lie is because
of vaud Americans PR machine just
pushing them on the public all about
merchandising all about sales obviously
now things are escalating into season
two because of their plan to try and get
superheroes in the military that's big
money and it's all about control because
what American doesn't just care about
money they make tons of money they want
real power and that's where you get into
the idea of putting superheroes in the
government and even eventually maybe
taking over the government so that plan
is just going to proceed through the
course of season 2 but as Huey's eyes
were opened and as this voiceover
implies in the teaser homeland her son's
eyes will also probably be open to the
truth that homeland er is a tear
a person sort of hyping up the idea of
homeland er versus his son but probably
not until we get to the series finale
because I do think the show will run for
at least a couple more seasons then
there's this footage of starlight in the
idea that she's slowly being corrupted
and embracing her bad side more she and
Hughie are actually written to have this
parallel story arc where they both start
out like these super innocent people who
would never hurt a fly but slowly
through the course of the series and
this is continuing into season two
they're driven to violence and
people like the supers that they're
trying to stop so even though in the
comics Hughie is dosed with compound V's
so he gets superpowers himself I don't
know if they're going to do that on the TV
show but they use their concurrent
storylines to ask the question of
whether or not they're becoming just as
bad as the people like homeland er for
Hughie he's always portrayed as the more
innocent of the two it's starlight that
actually starts to embrace her dark side
more and as you saw a vaud American is
starting to slut her up big time like
these are ads from season two that they
have around the set she starts to have a
less and less of a problem with that so
the question is is whether or not she's
going to become just as bad as a character
like Stormfront who I think is going to be
sort of a darkest timeline version of
what starlight might become during
season two the funny thing about that
too you think about how dark this gets
but this is them hanging out after
they've finished filming together like
you see starlight here sticking your
tongue out you see i Akash's stormfront
sitting next to homeland ER in the back
they're all just hanging out having fun
but talking about one of the other
biggest new characters that they're
introducing or they already introduced
they mentioned during season one but we
didn't actually see on-screen and that's
tech Knight he's a huge character in the
comics but he's super funny in a very
very disturbing messed-up way he was
created to be a parody of Batman and
Iron Man combined tech Knight as in
technology like Iron Man tech Knight has
no natural powers all of his abilities
come from the gear that he invents just
like Iron Man and Knight as in The Dark
Knight and in the past he had a sidekick
named laddie who was a version of Robin
who also left him when he got older to
become a version of Nightwing that they
call swing-wing on the series just like
Iron Man in Batman he's super rich and
has his own Batcave full of weapons and
machines that he uses this is a clip
from season one where they're actually
talking about the tech Knight character
during the superhero partners support
group for
people that were injured while they were
getting busy with superheroes some days
are harder than others obviously you
know the other day I wanted to talk to
my friend about all this but I couldn't
that's why this group is so great it's
so important I know it's wrong to feel
angry after all tech Knights saved me
just wish he'd been a little more gentle
with my spine it's about acceptance
isn't it letting go there was also a
separate tech night clip of the deep
doing a commercial talking about making
things more eco-friendly and referencing
that he made tech Knight make his
Batmobile more eco-friendly okay I mean
you'd say tech Knights Knight racer had
a carbon footprint the size of a 727
thing literally shot fire it's funny and
messed up is all that was like he gets
even worse as that scene goes on the way
were actually introduced to the tech
Knight character for the first time in
the actual story was way crazier he's in
a therapy session right at the beginning
of volume 2 because it has a compulsive
to getting down with anything
that he lays his eyes on even inanimate
objects and it was because of that
problem that he was kicked out of one of
the other major new superhero groups
called payback that's a group that's led
by Stormfront
also one of the new characters during
season two they go in a mission to take
down this hostile army in a foreign
territory but as they're flying back to
their headquarters he starts to stare at
his teammates but and just can't stop
thinking about it he winds up trying to
get with him mid-flight in the air and
everybody freaks out storm front and the
others immediately kick him out of the
payback team remember way back during
episode 1 when starlight was named as
the new member of the 7 it was a big
deal
originally that was supposed to be tech
Knight he was going to become a member of
the 7 but bought American found out
about his little quote-unquote problem
and vetoed his membership on the spot
the reason why butcher in the boys care
about tech Knight is because he actually
has something to do with their latest
new case which is given to them by
another really big new character called
the legend I
he's going to wind up being played by
Patton Oswalt because this is the Patton
Oswalt was playing a secret character in
who else would he play but this comic
book expert who the legend is designed
to be like the legend in the comics is
actually meant to be a parody of Stanley
he wants to police superheroes just like
the boys do but he trades mostly in
information so when you need information
on other superhero groups that's where
butcher goes they find out that the
legends grandson was a huge fan of tech
Knights former sidekick swing-wing the
version of Nightwing he was last seen
with swing-wing before he went missing
so the legend thinks that swing-wing
ended him and covered it up so he sends
the boys on the case and they go to tech
Knight to try and get information about
his former sidekick but while they're
there butcher uses his knowledge of
technics problem that he's been trying
to hide from the public trying to get
with all these inanimate objects forces
him to become an informant for the boys
inside the superhero community then
there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that happens with the technique Eric tur
but I don't want to get too spoilery
with it and I don't know how much of his
story from the comics they're going to do
during season two but he's sort of
adjacent to what's happening with all
the storm front stuff and all the stuff
with homeland err and the seven the
comic book goes off in a couple big
storylines in different directions
before it converges back on itself as
for the actual release date what
happened last week is they finished
filming season two in Karl Urban posted
this picture of them on set just
celebrating and also revealed they're
basically going to be releasing season two
around the exact same time that season 1 came out and if you remember that was
right at the end of July right after
Comic Con I think it was the week after
Comic Con so until they say something
more specific just assume it's going to be
sometime around then but I will be doing
more season 2 videos as we learn more
about what the show is doing in more
bonus videos and Easter eggs from the
comic books let me know in the comments
which other characters do you want them
to introduce during the boys season too
and if you have any big questions or
bonus videos that you want me to make
the really big stuff that's happening
this week is Rick and Morty season 4
episode 1 is dropping I'll be doing
weekly videos for that for all the
episodes Star Wars the Mandalorian
episodes are also starting - I'll be
doing weekly videos for that as well as
long as you have alerts enable for my
channel you should see all those videos
when I post them but if for some reason
you are having trouble finding specific
videos of mine just let me know in the
comments sometimes YouTube will change
things or things will break but it
should be fine
so everyone click here for the boys
season 2 trailer video in the first look
at the storm front character and click
here for that brand new
Spider-Man Into the Spider-Verse
2 Trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!